so gun ownership in America 300  Americans 200 million guns okay but only  a third of Americans own guns they just  on three at one time do you have like  say a white young person goes into  issues of the cinema and when the  newspaper tools survived it was about  their mental health and then when young  black male was shot even under the age  of 18 is like all their uncle's is a  drug dealer or they find something to  use to vilify that person you mentioned  Missouri and you mentioned Ohio and you  mentioned New York and South Carolina  and I think it's just important to say  that this is an American problem  this isn't isolated in one of those  places and we're gonna have to deal with  this as a country  you could actually see that he was  really passionate about some other  issues especially the gun issue and on  Syria well I imagined him to be taller  though because the gimmick is a picture  he looks tall